I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense it taught me to get along with
people no matter what I don't care where
you from care what your religion is I
don't care if you're poor if you're rich
it doesn't matter to me people are
people and when you're a foreigner in
someone else's country it teaches you to
be more sensitive to what other people's
culture is and understand people a
little bit better be a little bit more
forgiving and and that was great about
growing up in Europe I got a chance to
see the world well the kid so now I come
back here and I and it's like okay I can
get along with anybody because I've kind
of had to growing up unless you want it
to just kind of be that that that crazy
foreigner who just comes over and think
they're gonna just drop their culture on
us over here in our country who wants to
be that guy so it really taught me being
on a military base being around the
families of soldiers who were even from
all different parts of the country here
you have to learn to get along with
everybody and I'm innately like shy when
I'm not doing like TV stuff and
everything else we'll say I'm just
walking down the street with people they
might wait you know how to put inside I
kind of cringe I don't believe you Wow
weird is that have to do with the scene
part like feeling you had mentioned that
you feel scene and does that mean you
don't want to be seen on something don't
want to be see I want to be seen what I
want to be seen when I don't want to be
seen I don't want to be seen it's pretty
tough because you're a striking six foot
four or five stride from the teeth they
see the teeth and I think they're like a
tattoo it's like I gotcha yeah it's like
smile for me maybe makes it was you I'm
like do they do that oh absolutely
oh absolutely but yeah it is kind of
that I think kind of when I played
football first time I played football I
was seven years old I played when I was
seven and eight and in Germany I mean in
North Carolina in my first year seven
years old I was a really good player I
cried the entire game I didn't cry
because I was hurt I didn't cry because
I didn't want to be there I loved it I
cried because whenever I would make a
play the
clap and cheer and say my name bothered
seen it's weird
is this something you had to unravel in
your life yeah I had to me then you know
I get to college and it's like okay this
is kind of get used to it
because college was different for me
because we moved to Germany and on it I
was more European and I was American so
to come German a little bit like I can
you hungry I can get you food you drink
say like you know how are you it's nice
to be here
hello be gates hey how are you that was
[Laughter]
[Music]